une enclave au rythme de leur patrie
dans ce quartier de toronto on respire
les odeurs de l'accord et ses goûts et
ses nuances et ses subtilités
si cette famille passe presque inaperçue
et pourtant elle porte une lourde
histoire
nous avons accepté de cacher leur
identité car ils vivent toujours dans la
peur
prison pour des motifs politiques
torture ils ont tous connu derrière le
rideau de fer de la corée du nord à
oiseaux street
le fils a même vécu dans la rue à
mendier seul alors qu'il avait à peine
10 ans que je n'ai pas écouté mais la
mère fui vers la corée du sud travaillé
des années pour finalement en payer un
passeur et permettre à son fils de la
rejoindre 2005
selon chris km de la principale
organisation canadienne qui milite pour
les droits de la personne en corée du
nord
l'histoire de cette famille est
symptomatique d'un problème plus large
celui de la crise humanitaire qui sévit
dans ce pays dont les réfugiés sont
laissés à eux mêmes
alors que seule la corée du sud et
accepte or la vie en corée du sud est
difficile brutal parfois même pour les
réfugiés nord-coréens souvent
marginalisées persécutés au designer
coyotes et voilà pourquoi ils ont fui
vers le canada pour espérer obtenir le
statut de réfugié ils ont menti au min
de dire qu'ils étaient passés par cette
corée du sud
le mensonge voilà pourquoi aujourd'hui
le canada menace de les expulser
explique leur avocate et schneider
ammann chef allardyce permettre l espère
convaincre le ministre de l'immigration
et des schémas nationaux de leur
octroyer un permis spécial sur une base
humanitaire
dans la joie qui anime ce joli parc la
peur qu'ils espéraient oublier les
hantent de nouveau à dente car le régime
de pyongyang risque de nous recherchés
explique le père
nous ne voulions que changer d'identité
être à l'abri de commonit comédien
alors que la planète a les yeux rivés
sur les enjeux sécuritaires entourant la
corée du nord puisqu'il croit que la
question des réfugiés offre une
opportunité unique pour le canada ottawa
se doit de mettre sur pied un programme
pour permettre aux canadiens parrainer
des réfugiés nord-coréens plaide-t-il
aïe ça parce que je suis canadien j'ai
des amis ici j'étudie je saurai y
contribuer à la société explique le fils
d'earl jones and the star dans la peur
d'un nouveau départ ils s'accrochent à
leur rêve canadien
[Musique]